on this episode we talk about going out
of business you ask questions and I
answer them this is the askgaryvee shut
up
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 96 of the askgaryvee
show hope everybody had a wonderful
Mother's Day hope you enjoy that I hope
you had the wonderful weather we had in
New York City that was very nice very
warm yesterday little grumpy this
morning dear ox team this morning beat
my team three out of four times and
basketball nothing to do with D Rock but
you know but they won anyway and yeah Oh
anyway episode 100 of the askgaryvee
show is a week from today it looks like
we are going to be doing it at the
Gansevoort hotel we will update later
today I'm not sure when this is airing
in return but by tomorrow that will be
firmed up but pretty sure it's gonna be
on the Gansevoort hotel on Park Avenue
we'll get all those updates on the
Facebook reminder will blast that out on
the Gary VIP email list will link it up
on tomorrow's episode of askgaryvee
everybody listening on the podcast you
can check out on Facebook I'll probably
set out a link on Twitter as well there
may be a limit so we need to talk about
that also
after I'm done taping I know a lot of
maniacs vaynernation coming I'd like
them to hang out with each other I've
got to go to a business meeting at Citi
Field a Mets game it's in the back of my
mind and maybe come back in the city
10:30 to 11:30 and maybe do a drink up
somewhere keep that in the back of your
mind because they notice a lot of Peter
and O's coming as I'm in fact if you're
coming please in the Facebook and the
YouTube sections tell me where you're
coming from seems like a lot of people
are very localized makes sense people
some people are making the schlep and
the schlep excites me India let's get
into the show
Jarrod ass I have an Ave idea with my
target market willing to test it but I
need to create an app and I'm not a
programmer any advice yeah this this
question pisses me off because I'm asked
this all the time I probably get about
30 40 of these emails a week I'm not
sure if you're trying to get on the show
or if you really mean it this seems like
the simplest thing to do in the world
I mean meetup.com has 800 different
developer meetups and if you want it bad
enough you go to the closest one even if
it's 75 miles away
there's just eight
in communities of developers out there
this literally when I get an email from
somebody saying hey Gary I've got the
next big idea but I need a developer
literally immediately I go like this I
read it I'm Chuck might let's let's
reenact it oh let me just catch up on my
rock I'll do that later
let me just real let me check something
else hey Gary love the show you're the
best person I've ever met yet it had oh
by the way I have a big time idea except
I need a developer out of business if
you are not capable if you're not
capable of finding your business partner
developer then how in the world are you
gonna win in business ideas are [ __ ]
executions the game let's move on shady
what up baby it's shady India you're
into shady right by name only good shady
ass what are bad habits you had and
overcame and had it overcoming them aid
your growth as an entrepreneur stayed a
good question not like the last one I
think the things I overcame were big
eyes which was hey I'm gonna do a lot of
things at once actually I don't know if
I've ever comment I've got a little bit
better definitely in this chapter of
building vaynermedia I've overcome that
issue I've been really focused the CEO
of vaynermedia
and general partner of vayner/rse so
I've been really focused and so big eyes
just trying to do too many things at
once and what that's allowed me to do is
be successful and build another big
business instead of half pregnant across
the board I think the other thing that
I've overcome is I've started and I'm
still not great at this either these are
always works in progress when it's not
the thing that comes most natural to you
but I think what I've been doing well
lately is I've been giving more honest
critical direct to people's face
feedback you know I tend to be a little
bit softer I'm much more of a honey over
vinegar guy but you know between our
former managing director Kellie and AJ
the very straight shooter operators that
they've moved me along
I've definitely evolved in that category
I've definitely better at it I still
want to have deal with a ton of empathy
and and heart and soul but shooting it
straight is bringing more value to me
and it's just speeding up the process of
victory can't have a CEO
I don't I wouldn't say I'm not I'm very
decisive but boy you know delivering bad
news does not come natural to me and I
don't love it and so building
infrastructure around me and then doing
it myself has been an important
evolution that I've done much better at
being a media than I've done a wine
library and what that's given me is the
thing that a lot of you know that I
value which is speed those to
Christopher ass Gary how can I prevent
angel investors interested in investing
in my enterprise for potentially
stealing our IP Christopher this is a
really interesting Monday morning show
Christopher this is also a [ __ ] question
ideas or [ __ ] executions the game people
walking around gank Gary please sign
this NDA before I pitch you my idea as
an angel investor
let me flip me let me reenact it let me
just indie I'll get to that later let me
just catch up on me know hey Gary really
big fan your best guy I've ever met
anyway uh the SEC of this big time idea
but before I pitch it to you please see
the following attachment and sign the
NDA because I just can't let you see it
I don't want it stolen great delete out
of business if you literally think in
2015 that your idea is so profound and
nobody's ever thought of it that when I
sit with you and I pitch I go you're a
dope but I'm going to take this idea and
give it to somebody else you were lost
in the reality of the marketplace again
if that is where your mindset is that I
just don't see that as a winning mindset
for 2015 and beyond the days of patent
or idea IP and for know every idea has
been thought about there's nobody who's
come up with a big-time idea I'm telling
you every idea has been thought about
all of them every one of them people
executing or having the pieces in place
to be able to execute or the right time
in their career or the right resources
financially energy skills opportunities
those are the variables not the ideas
it's a nasty show what is it
what's that three things that we got a
straight up as an asset what is episode
96 this is nasty 96 is nasty
vaynernation Steve our very own Steve
ass which marketing vehicles are working
best to grow the businesses of this
oops you've invested it Steve a hardcore
vaynermedia employee working on data and
insights wonder if this is a hedged
question or not but Steve the answer to
this question is clearly Facebook dark
posts I've pounded this over and over I
don't think it's funny the real the
vaynermedia clients don't recognize
what's going on all my investment
companies are only playing in this space
you know I'm gonna look it up right now
in real time I'm gonna predict right
here on the spot that wish the app wish
the shopping app is probably in the top
150 in the App Store this is a company
met the founder can last year the big
advertising festival just go through
this Facebook Facebook by the way dub
mash I missed it oh god I met I Skyped
with the founder of dub mash from Berlin
like seven weeks ago so on it 1015 weeks
that I screwed it up
snapchat okay this is what I do all the
time by the way the rock you can focus
here every every so often actually
didn't do it this morning which is fun
to do it I'm just always looking at the
top 100 apps to basically get a feel
usually actually we're a most excited
about is down here right because you
know the top is pretty consistent but
it's anything popped up here like you
know wall a pop you know like those kind
of things I'm always kind of trying to
see let me just see if wishes here
somewhere happen awareness 112 zoom in
baby 112 all Facebook dark posts and I
mean all Facebook dark posts if people
understood what was going on arbitrage
wise on Facebook dark posts right now
which is the slang term Facebook
advertising platform where you can reach
anybody that you want if people
understood that they would win every
single time just like Google AdWords in
the early 2000s that Amazon and eBay
used to build their businesses still
can't believe people don't understand
this is what happened
Facebook is absolutely the place that
I'm that you can't milk enough of that
cow right now and again over the next 24
to 48 months it will disappear and it
will more more or less level out and
become appropriate right now it's under
price in four years I'll still love it
intuitively I believe
but it's going to be appropriate I'll be
like this is worth it just exactly worth
it not this is worth 8 bucks and I'm
paying a dollar for it so Facebook dark
posts if if my startups could spend
every penny they had they would on that
place Pinterest starting to emerge a
little bit as well no I want those [ __ ]
ones to sit
amber ass hey Gary what would you
prioritize is a one-person business
amber that's how you roll ladies that
was an Al I don't know you can see
that's what got me the ladies amber
amber it's a great question and a very
simple one to be honest with you and I
see you know India just informed me
about the artistic side of what you're
pumping out and so this will be kind of
interesting I'm an answer but it's the
truth if there was one thing I would
spoke Ahsan as a solopreneur it is sales
money is oxygen you know and so you know
you could do anything you want you could
produce the greatest art the greatest
thinkers the greatest cup of coffee if
you don't know how to sell it
you are out of business which tends to
be the theme of this episode and so I
would highly recommend you focus on
sales you have to figure out can you
sell your thing whatever that is it's a
service sell out the show your thing
that you actually sell if you're not
capable of selling as a solopreneur
there's really nothing else that matters
because money intake is the way you
continue to the next move
right it's it's it's like up up down
down left right left right B a B a
select start powers up your lives in
Contra like you need lives and cash is
that Nintendo cheat sheet hack and so
that's what it is cash is oxygen cash
say with me vaynernation cash is oxygen
cash is oxygen cash is oxygen come on
cash come on idiot doing with me cash
they come on cash is oxygen yes
yes this is a very special very special
96th episode on
ask Gary B show the internation question
today cache is fill in the blank you
keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]